Okay, so tell me when we saw that Alice's algorithm for finding a valid vertex cover
is very inefficient but fairly easy to program too, so I'd like to go ahead and try and implement this
and we'll do this in two separate parts.
First, I want you to find a procedure validity check that returns true if and only if the given cover
is a valid vertex cover for the graph that is input, and the graph is going to be a list of lists,
an adjacency matrix like we have seen before, and the cover is simply going to be a list
of the same length as the number of vertices in the graph.
So for example for the given graph, if we attempted to cover of say A and C,
then the cover that we would input to validity check would be 1, 0, 1, 0, and the graph
that we would have be 0, 1, 1, 0 inside the list 1, 0, 1, 0; 1, 1, 0, 1; 1, 0, 0, 1, 0, again in a list.
So these would be our inputs to validity check here.
So I want you to do is fill in the rest of this function here.
The next thing that I want you to do is fill in vertex cover naive where it simply takes the input graph
as a list of list as an adjacent to matrix and finds the minimum vertex cover of that input graph,
and you can use the validity check to do this.
So your code should check if the assignment is valid for a given assignment, should calculate
the size of the assignment, and then it should update the minimum vertex cover variable if appropriate.
So okay. Great. I hope you have fun with this problem.